>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> The Law Library of Congress
holds a collection of trials
in its rare book collection.
This particular trial was a
sensation and is often thought
of as the trial of the
century for the 19th century.
Morris Cohen's Bibliogragy
of Early American Law lists
several reports of this case.
This particular one was
published by R.M. De Witt as one
of Dewitt's Special Reports
and is reported by
Felix G. Fontaine.
It started when the wife of Rep.
Daniel Sickles, Teresa
Sickles, had an affair
with Philip Barton Key.
Philip Key was the son
of Francis Scott Key,
who you may know as the author
of the Star Spangled Banner.
It has been said that all
of Washington society knew
of his wife's affair
except for Sickles,
until one day he received a
mysterious note signed "R.P.G."
that revealed the affair and
how Key contacted Teresa.
Sickles confronted Teresa
and made her write a
handwritten confession
that was later published.
As Sickles and his friends
were discussing what to do
about the situation, they
spotted Key signaling Teresa
from the street with
his handkerchief.
Sickles confronted
Key in the street.
Armed with two derringers
and a revolver,
Sickles fired upon Key,
but only grazed him.
Key reached into his own
coat for a means of defense,
but found only opera glasses,
which he threw at Sickles.
Key wrestled with Sickles,
and Sickles dropped his gun.
Freeing himself from Key's grip,
Sickles produced another gun,
and Key began to stumble
backwards, crying,
"Don't shoot me,
don't murder me!"
Sickles fired, striking
Key in the groin.
Key fell, and Sickles
drove a point-blank shot
into Key's chest.
Finally, Sickles put
a gun to Key's head
and pulled the trigger,
but the gun misfired.
A group of men arrived
on the scene,
and Sickles was led away
while Key lay dying.
It would seem Sickles would
almost certainly be convicted
of murder, but he was defended
by a team of prominent lawyers,
including the future Secretary
of War, Edwin Stanton.
The defense successfully argued
that Sickles was in a state
of temporary insanity.
Sickles later served as a
Union General at the Battle
of Gettysburg where he
was struck by cannon fire,
resulting in the
amputation of his leg.
Sickles' leg is periodically
displayed at the National Museum
of Health and Medicine.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit
us at LOC.gov.